Lisey's Story is my favorite.
It always has been.
At its core, this is a love story.
It's a story of a woman's courage,
who would do almost anything
to save her husband's life and sanity.
Lisey is a different thing for me.
It's very close to my heart.
I had pneumonia around the year 2000
and came really close to stepping out.
When I came home from the hospital,
my wife had cleaned out my study.
and I thought to myself,
"I've died. I'm a ghost."
And the idea for Lisey's Story
came from that,
particularly the idea that writers,
when they make things up,
they go to a different world.
I wanted to tell the story
that was in the book,
but I wanted to make it better.
I thought if somebody was
going to mess it up,
I used to tell my wife,
"Nobody's going to mess it up but me."
The story of Scott's childhood,
when he finally tells it,
is particularly horrific.
He retreats into this fantasy world.
Boo'ya Moon is his secret place.
It's a place that's very,
very beautiful,
and at the same time,
very dangerous.
It's a very scary story,
in a lot of ways.
It's scary in a supernatural way,
but it's also scary because...
there really are
dangerous people out there.
Lisey's Story could only have come
from the mind of Stephen King.
It's beautiful and haunting,
and romantic and horrifying.
When I think of Lisey's Story,
like I think of Stephen King,
and how is this connected with his life.
It was a lot of pressure, too.
We wanted to make sure
that we did him justice,
and that we did the story justice.
I'm a visual writer.
I'm interested in
the power of the imagination.
We can talk about it as
otherworldly and fantastic.
He's like,
"Oh, no, it's real. It's real."